good afternoon we are now
live well good morning good afternoon
everyone my name is Vincent G I'm the
director general of the ftth council
Europe it's my pleasure to host um and
moderate this this session it's called
Global policy and regulation review and
it's organized by the fiber to the home
Global Alliance uh while we waiting for
U more participant to join us I will um
maybe pause for another 30 seconds and
formally start the call so bear with us
we're just waiting for more participant
to join us and we will kick off formally
the session in in a few seconds thank
you
well I think we are um now getting a
good uh number of participants thank you
for for joining us um
a few uh housekeeping item uh before we
start so the the session will be
recorded um link to the the replay will
be sent to all of you uh after the call
so you uh you will have access and you
will be able to to share the um the
replay um you went through the
registration process you you gave your
consent so you will probably receive uh
further ftth Council Europe webinar uh
series uh event notification for for the
future um just to note that um you can
use the question uh box in the control
panel to ask question which uh we will
try and take uh at the end of the
session so we will share that with our
panelists at the end of the session and
if if not covered during the session we
will make sure we come back to you uh if
we've not been able to address this
question so use the question box if you
if you wish um
the the session today uh is organized by
the ftth council Global Alliance fcga
acronym it might not sound familiar for
most of you but this is actually a an
alliance of all um Association which
across the world are promoting the
acceleration uh of adoption and roll out
of full fibon Network to the home for
the benefits of Citizen and businesses
across the world um and it includes uh
the following organization digital
Council Africa the fiber Broadband
Association which covers Northern
America the fiber Broadband Association
Lam so which is the the Latin America
chapter of the FBA the fiber Network
counil APAC covering uh Asia Pacific and
um
region and fiber connect Council Mina
Mina standing for Middle East North
Africa and finally the ftt council
Europe which I have the pleasure to to
lead and we are meeting together we are
organizing uh activity together what you
see here on the slide uh is is two of
the latest project we run and this
webinar is co-organized by these
organization to present um the outcome
of our latest um common work which is
called Global policy and regulation
review and which has the ambition to um
take stock of what is the situation of
these very important drivers for ftth
deployment which are public policy and
uh regulation so we have surveyed um via
the different organization the situation
in a variety of country across the world
um and we try and regroup in this
document uh the key findings about uh
commonalities but also differences via
five or six chapter and the purpose of
this call is to go through the chapter
and ask our panelist to to comment uh on
the variety of situation we Face across
the world this document is available uh
for you immediately via the handout
section of a control panel if you go on
at the bottom of your control panel you
should see hands out there is one
document one PDF you can download uh and
that's the report I'm just uh showing
the cover page to you right
now now um it's time to introduce you to
to our speaker lineup uh we're still
waiting for uh two of them to join us
but I'm sure they will um um they will
come in a in a few in a few seconds um
starting with Juanita Juanita Clark your
chief executive of digital Council
Africa and you're calling from Jonesburg
I
think Victoria same place same place
okay well uh thanks to to be with us uh
we also joined uh by Dr sulman uh ad uh
you're representing fiber connect
Council
Mina thank you very much to to be with
us and you're calling from Riyad Saudi
Arabia yes I'm sure I'm I'm I'm
representing fiber connect cons
Mina thank you very much and um Franco
accordino um just join us right on time
thank you so much Franco for for being
with us good morning and thanks for
inviting thank you and and Franco is
head of unit investment in high capacity
Network at the European Mission uh dig
connect um and of course he he he will
bring his expertise uh in the topic of
public policy regulation specifically uh
describing the situation in Europe and
we should normally uh very rapidly be be
joined by Frank Jeffer who represent
fiber Network Council APAC so you see
not all um of the six organization are
represented a second webinar is
organized later this afternoon uh I mean
afternoon uh European Time at 5:00 p.m C
and we'll focus on the situation also
covering uh North America and Latin
America so we for obvious time zone
reason we have to to present this this
outcome via two
sessions so um let me move to um I would
say the first chapter which has been
covered by um by our review by this
white paper and that concerns the legal
and Regulatory
framework um why policy and regulation
matters what are their impact on
accessibility um what is the how do they
handle the question of affordability
equality and how do they contribute to
Foster uh adoption so the review is
really uh looking at this points uh and
what we see is that of course there are
a variety of situations and some region
like Europe are very centralized others
are um much more decentralized in the
way regulation is apply there are some
Regional harmonization efforts taking
place um the the question of consumer
protection is very often uh key also in
variety of region so that is one chapter
of the the document that I would like to
open discussion about but we would like
to combine it with an second uh topic
that the report covers which concerns
deployment Target public policy and
regulator framework uh always need to be
uh organized around a political
objective and very often the deployment
of fiber is part of a series of
political Target um and Ambitions for
the citizens so it can take a variety of
uh of of ways depending on the country
and that's also one point that we will
discuss um what are the political policy
um ambition in term and how Define are
the targets depending on the on the
regions so that that covers the I would
say the first introduction and I would
like to to open um to to our panelists
right now um on this topic um maybe
starting um with you Franco um asking
the the question what are the
the challenges in achieving the
deployment Target in your region maybe
starting also by explaining at the EU
level how do we Define uh deployment
Target for what is called in the EU
jargon very high capacity network uh
which is in many cases uh a proxy for
for ftth networks indeed thank you
van uh well first of all I have to say
it's not the first time that we Define
policy Target in the union I mean we
started already 20 years ago and every
let's say five years to 10 years we
review them and we adapt to the
technological challenges now we are
focusing on the targets set for 2030
soal digital decade targets those are
very ambitious simply because of the
Universal Character of these targets we
really want every corner every household
in Europe be connected with the gig bit
capacity uh which means in most of the
cases you're right means
ftth um uh but of course giving the
challenges that we have the the variety
you know diversity of type of geot
types uh that we have in Europe from the
mountains down to you know to less or
more populated areas we cannot claim
that this is really achieved so so uh so
easily so that is the first challenge I
would say to reconcile this very
ambitious Target with the fact that we
have to to do our utmost uh to um atmost
to to to progress steadily because 2030
is not so far away and we really want
every household to be connected uh so um
of course uh other challenge uh is
investment we have calculated that in
order to achieve I mean you have also
referred to the the into the report uh
even though the number
174 uh includes also the connectivity 5G
Target as well but if we really look
only at the fixed connectivity it's
certainly quite consistent Gap is more
than 110 is 114 I think or 15 billion
Euro from now to to end of the decade so
where to find this money so this is a
big challenge of course uh because of
course it's clear that in certain area
the more difficult the more challenging
public intervention is a must um at the
same time public alone cannot uh do
everything so it's important to promote
public private private Partnerships ER
Co Investments and of course I will
elaborate on that in the next uh round
because otherwise I take too long but so
ambitious Targets this is the the first
really step to be done and I think it
helps a lot in shaking in moving
creating certain Dynamics but of course
a whole set of a company measures are
needed on the regulatory dimension on
the policy Dimension itself and of
course on investments that's our
recipe thank you so much Franco maybe
moving to to Juanita um you you're
covering um a also very diverse uh part
of the world um so how do you see in
your region in in in subsaharian Africa
uh that concept of um Target and uh
accompanying um and and all the the
complementary regulatory framework being
developed in in the different
countries thank you Vincent and um yeah
it's a pleasure always to engage with my
colleagues from around the world um you
know it's it's to some extent it's not
very different to Europe you know you
you you've got same challenges and uh
you know investment ongoing investment
is a very big problem um and to you know
pick up uh and and continuously um get
investment into the sector um naturally
is um and always has been a big problem
I think you know we always talk about
that Ripple in the pond sort of effect
you know everybody always goes after the
most affluent areas and the big um
challenge right now is how do we how do
we service those areas where the
business case doesn't make sense and
doesn't Stack Up and um you know we
we've got some some great initiatives
that's happening uh you know there are a
lot of work that's coming out of um of
from the subaran um Africa continent um
people are finding methodologies to
deploy at at lower costs um you know and
and I think you know there's a lot of
countries in the world that can take a
leave from the South African book um in
terms of how to really reduce this but
um you know there are no government in
Africa that have that have stated
specific targets we've seen mention um
similarly to in um you know in Europe
that fiber is the desirable um you know
infrastructure but but in Africa you
can't take any any technology really off
the table completely because there will
be areas where fiber just will never
make sense especially in deep rural
areas um but by example in South Africa
there's an estimated other 14 million
people that still have to be connected
many of those households are lower
income households and finding the
investment appetite to deploy into those
areas facing the challenges that comes
with deploying into those areas um you
know remains um remains an obstacle um
but there are some um you know companies
that have indicated that they would like
to um play in that market we we've seen
um you know one or two sort of um access
fund initiatives that's um in the
process of being launched um with some
mixed successes um unfortunately often
government does do understand what those
PPP should look like and and how to
incentivize private sector um and
unfortunately sometimes these mechanisms
are developed um in isolation without
input from private sector who then don't
make use of those those mechanisms um
but um but there's there's progress and
you know we believe that we're going to
achieve that um those targets also as a
as a
203 um you know trying to find um have
at least 80% of uh our communities
connected well thank you w um maybe
moving now to Dr siman on on the same
point of public Target and um regulatory
framework and public policy to to
achieve this target uh what can we say
on this topic for for the Middle East uh
and and Northern Africa
region thank you so much for inviting me
to this webinar in the Mina region it's
it's it's completely uh uh in line with
with uh my what my colleagues have
mentioned about Investments you know as
you know fiber deployments they require
uh amber
resources and uh in in the Middle East
uh we have uh maybe different challenges
also which is the political and
instability CH challenges in in many of
the Middle East countries uh if you look
at the segmentation of the Middle East
uh for instance the Gulf region is is is
very uh they have very advantage that
most governments are wealthy and they
are willing to invest in in their
Broadband
initiatives um nearly half of of the
Mina countries they have Broadband plans
and and they mostly are very very
ambitious plans unfortunately attaining
these plans uh sometimes slow go down
due to uh the investment issue in
addition to the political issues uh so
uh you can
see in the middle the Gulf region we
have like six very mature uh uh
countries uh with respect to
connectivity with fiber
Broadband uh then you go to other uh
countries whereby there are uh very good
potentials for for uh broadband and and
especially fiber connectivity like Iraq
Morocco
Egypt however they are still really
struggling with with few issues and
investment is is very important because
most Investments are are
really initiated by government bodies in
in some cases we have the World Bank and
and the European Union also they
contribute to some disadvantageous
countries where they give loans and and
for infrastructure projects including
telecommunication
projects however uh the plans are always
ambitious and and and many countries
have targets for 2030 and 2035 and
2040 uh and and they are progressing in
these
plans however in other countries it's
it's a bit
slow but we Face the the the very same
challenges thank you very much dman
Franco you wanted to react to yes just
uh very interesting indeed thank you
really for sharing this information
which is also important for us I think
we can draw reciprocal advantage of this
session just want to complement and S
because maybe I feel I didn't address
100% your your question so uh regulatory
from a regul yes I think as you know in
within the union we have uh main source
of Regulation which is the European
commission that is empowered by the
council and the Parliament we make
proposal and then with their Cod
decision they become low uh in most
cases uh directly applicable in some Cas
to be transposed by the member states
now
um uh if you ask is is the regulation up
to to the challenge I would say so far
it has worked quite well we know we have
a competition which is extremely Pro
competitive and pro consumer I would say
uh so on one side this has has been of
course key for uh for putting things in
motion and you know aligning with the
targets Etc we have the European uh
communication code um
uh but on the other side of course you
might say Okay an excessively Pro
competitive market which is also
excessively fragmented doesn't uh allow
to pull resources and then continue the
investment path to achieve the target so
this is a general issue second point
that is really peculiar to the union I
would say compared also to the other
regions perhaps not all of them is the
fact that we have a lot of legacy and
now this Legacy of course uh uh has been
maintained and uh you know exploited
until the very last moment and will
continue to be exploited so of course we
can be more or less interventionist with
the regulation but we have to cope with
that with that transition so switch over
or other things look at the Dilemma big
dilemma that the cable operators in
countries like I don't know Germany or
or even Belgium or uh big dilemma that
they are facing when they say okay
should we continue with the c move on
with the next standard protocol or we
should rather sooner than later start
the switching toward the fiber to the
home so those are big existential
question for those big companies of
course which is really peculiar to to
the European context I would say more
than perhaps other regions so in this
respect I would say the other regions
have a little bit of more Advantage
because it's a more green field type of
investment and therefore they can
proceed very fast as it happened with
the mobile but of course as uh Mr suan
said I mean money can't matter here so
it's it's quite uh quite challenging the
big gap that we have in front of us
sorry I wanted just to complement no and
probably also the situation in Europe if
if I a Franco uh with the with the the
the the complexity of as you said the
Legacy um infrastructure is also what
what uh made um relatively complex
regulatory framework important to uh to
ensure that it can be done with with
with an Healy competition which has
helped um Drive private investment which
was one of the point you you mentioned
earlier excellent any on on on this
question of because we're going to move
to to the next chapter but maybe any
other consideration on on this point of
uh targets and
um public policy regulatory framework
um no um I think we we can easily um
move to to the to the next chapter
because the the the topic are actually
also very much interconnected uh we were
talking about investment we were talking
about the importance of funding access
especially to areas where um pure
private investment are not necessarily
commercially viable and where public
intervention is necessary uh Dr slan you
mentioned also in some cases the
intervention of international
organization like the World Bank to
support connectivity as a key driver for
economic development in many areas uh of
the world and it's clear that the the
the review is covering that point um
together with public Target and public
public policy um government acknowledge
and public institution acknowledge the
need to help financially um achieve
these targets um with maybe and I think
this is something which we find in every
region an emphasis on a remote rural
area where the level of density makes
the business case very difficult for
private
entrepreneurs or maybe uh to a to a
maybe at Country level uh with
International Organization supporting
development plans uh for countries where
the public uh available money for this
type of investment might not be
sufficient so maybe um when um starting
with you um what has been your
experience of the situation of Public
Funding uh and uh public um incentives
uh in your
region um Vincent you know unfortunately
uh a lot of these funding mechanisms
have not worked previously and and you
know there's there's very often there's
no trust between private sector and
government that government can actually
you know fulfill on um on some of the
incentive mechanisms that they've put
out we've just seen in South Africa the
Broadband access fund um was announced
there was a proof of concept plan with
national govern government to the value
of 200 million um but that that uh proof
of concept excluded um traditional fiber
Network operators um or the larger fiber
Network operators from participating in
uh government was very clear on the fact
that only um smme can participate in it
but simultaneously they Place such
cumbersome um rules on smmes that it's
almost impossible for the smm to adere
to the rules and regulations that were
implemented by by government so often
regret government comes with really good
intentions I mean really good intentions
to promote smme uh to make sure that you
know the value chain benefits from
Government funding Etc but the rules
then for participation means that smmes
are naturally excluded um you know from
participating in in the funds and and
then the funds you know comes to a
grinding H so nothing nothing happens
and nothing comes out of that and you
know there's lots of questions around
sustainability of government funded
networks um you know we we prefer match
funded networks you know where the
operators still have some so to speak
skin in the game you know that it's not
entirely funded um you know there's an
obligation um from them to still make
sure that the network um you know
performs because you know they've still
got um a share um you know in that and
they have to ensure that it works um we
are looking at alternative mechanisms
for funds now where we can go to
operators and establish a fund um you
know
and and and exploring what those funds
then would look like what would get the
fos excited um but you know while we're
doing that there are other Technologies
um that's really coming into Africa um
you know Elon Musk starlink and other
Technologies which are which are now
coming in because there's some market
failure you know from the fos while they
they're looking to um you know build out
these networks and you know there are
other um technologies that is coming
into to as we we say in Africa to eat
their lunch um you know so we need to um
you know just make sure that we we sit
down we understand with between public
and private sector what a what a typical
fund should look like and then make sure
that everybody's got equal equal access
to those um those funds but to make sure
that you know we still benefit the
supply chain so how do operators bring
smmes into their supply chain train them
up and make sure that there's a role so
that we we you know we uh that everybody
in supply chain can benefit from this um
but but it's a fine balance and time
will tell whether we can get it
right thank you so much and Dr San do
you see the same um challenges around
how public fund public initiative are
are used uh you were mentioning in your
introduction that a lot of the
deployment in many country is uh
government
funded you you're on mute
apologies yes government plays the main
role actually for for funding and
incentives and and when they do
Unfortunately they focus on the uncomp
operators simply because most
governments in the Middle East they
majority own The Operators the The
uncomp Operators uh however now it's a
bit it's changing in in some of the in a
few countries like Saudi Arabia for
instance the uh the government has given
a big project back in
2017 uh it
was targeting uh to connect 2 million uh
households within three years and and
they allocated around $4.5
billion of funding to three operators
one of them is the un comp operate in
addition some other governments they are
really establishing their own Broadband
company like Oman
Broadband in Oman and also like theat in
Saudi Arabia which is owned by the
utility company uh those two companies
are basically wholesalers whereby they
deploy fiber and and then they uh
wholesale as per a bitstream uh type
of of agreements with other operators in
addition we have so many alternative
operators who
actually sometimes fund projects fund
their own networks uh and now with the
Open Access uh initiatives in in in
several countries uh and also these
alternative operators are mostly uh GSM
operators whereby they provide 5G and
now they are finding necessary to also
invest in fiber or actually to uh make
agreements with the with the wholesalers
uh to utilize their fiber Network and I
think this is a very positive sign for
for several of these alternative
operators whereby they will extend their
networks in addition they will make use
of the existing uh uh wholesale networks
to provide uh connectivity to Hom
uh therefore I think 5G is helping in
that matter and and we see all over the
Middle East the the GSM is a
pre-dominant
technology especially the 4G and the 5G
now whereby many homes are are really uh
utilizing the Broadband connectivity
through
GSM
uh however GSM cannot work with with
with without fiber which is a very good
sign that most of the back huling and
and also the the backbone of most
countries is utilizing the the the
fiber
backod and also we still have Legacy
systems and and not too many countries
are are willing to give up these Legacy
systems especially in in Africa uh they
are still utilizing DSL in many other
countries in the 11th countries also DSL
is still
predominant however I think there is
progress It's it's slow but it's there
and we're hoping that that many
governments will help on that in
addition we see a few investment from uh
from uh real estate developers
especially in Egypt they have many uh
closed compounds where these real estate
developers they have their own network
at least the network inside the compound
then they will uh sign agreements with
different
operators for
services okay so variety of of of
situation um
Franco you this is your core activity
investment and uh what can you w within
within your your responsibility at the
European Union but um what is the part
of Public Funding versus private funding
how do you find the right balance and
and where is Public Funding uh channeled
towards um in in the in the framework of
the uh EU uh policy in favor of a very
high capacity
Network thank you V and again thank you
to the previous speakers for uh so rich
uh uh sharing of information which is
very useful well I mean of course short
answer is of course the public should
intervene in market failure areas if the
market fails to to bring fiber of course
that is where we we are we authorize
governments being them at Regional or
national level to intervene so we have a
quite updated state aid guidelines for
that in identifying helping identifying
market failure uh we have raised a
little bit the stick where states can
intervene without notifying uh to the
commission
um uh and also uh facilitating also the
cases where they have to notify
explaining you know that that it's
important really to giving a message
that is important to really move rapidly
with investment toward the gigabit uh
Target now um of course I mean the the
question of investment is rather complex
because one of the reason why some areas
we
fail uh we proceed slow slowly is the
fact that the demand is proceeding
slowly a little bit everywhere
especially when you have
Alternatives um that are let's say not
comparable from the point of view of the
physical you know characteristics of of
the the um of the of of fiber versus
whatever other type of of uh of
Technology uh but certainly I mean there
is a lot to do in explaining the users
of the benefit also in terms of
long-term
perspective um so in this respect also
governments could opt uh to also balance
interventions in uh coverage uh with
interventions on the demand side demand
side measures vouchers for for instance
smmes or uh families with the special
needs or whatever in order to already
put things in motion gain and show the
value of having a gigabit connectivity
VHC and networks at home um uh then the
European landscape is also characterized
by the presence of public important
Public Funding uh instruments uh we have
you mentioned the report the erdf so
those are uh funds that are let's say uh
shared whose manage which management is
shared between between the union and the
members States and sometimes very often
is delegated to the regions and uh um um
gigabit networks are fully eligible
under these uh these programs and
therefore in most cases those are are
used uh very effectively we have
launched
the the RF uh the recovery resilience
facility uh which and and then we have
seen a number of member State put a
significant part of it in connectivity H
so that that was really fantastic of
course now the challenge is to to make
it happen because when you have so many
projects uh parallel you know proceeding
in parallel of course there are issues
of finding the the workforce uh of
course to dig and to but we we are very
confident on that finally uh let me
mention of course the connecting Euro
facility program where basically we we
use it more as a as um
as a best practice program um uh where
we I mean it's focused mostly on
backbone networks I must say because
bamon networks are absolutely
fundamental to connect States Etc
including some cables not really Central
to these to this session but of course
being in an international context it's
important to know that with the SE
program we can connect Union with the
Third Country so uh giving unfortunately
the context we are living today
witnessing today it's important to
provide the union and I guess every
other region with the necessary level of
resilience of those infrastructures uh
some are in cables first but could be
also terrestrial obviously um so last
but not least allow me to say another
two things which are perhaps more or
less peculiar to the European context
the fact we have a European investment
bank which she which helps a lot with
their own invest you guarantee can
invest also outside Union in certain
cases where there is an interest of
course um uh for the union to invest uh
but we have also the IND the uh
Investments of our International
partnership funds and Global Europe
which allow also investing outside Union
in particular for instance in Africa um
and last but not least as I said before
it's also a matter of demand it's also a
matter of promoting new business models
and let also the T sector transforming
itself for this purpose I think there is
a lot that we can do one of the things
that we do we have a every year
Broadband Awards it seems to be really
more marketing type of action but it can
be useful in promoting alternative
business models and investment models so
I could just extemporaneously make a
proposal to all of you let's have a a
Broadband award in in every region
because this can help think also making
even more promotional activity and
explaining the importance of of bringing
uh proper connectivity to
everyone thank you very much Franco and
it's true that uh in some cases you see
a lot of public money being supporting
deployment in rural area and in other
cases to your point in term of business
model we see very agile and Nimble uh
operator managing to to to develop
activity commercially VI activity in the
very same region just by adapting their
model and Performing very well without
public investment so there are variety
situations if you allow me to complement
then I mean I think we should explore
and the public side should probably
value more the possibility to to to go
invest into investment funds dedicated
to infrastructures we have an example
for that where the government of course
puts a first loss piece in order to Der
risk the the investment of the private
so once the private in they are in uh of
course the idea is to divest uh the so
our job is not the one of playing in the
market but to facilitate the market so
in this respect I would be curious maybe
in another meeting to to learn if there
are example like these in the other
regions we have a few example for that
the cpf is one uh and our goal is there
really again to uh uh leverage private
uh uh Investments alongside the European
Investment Bank and the so-called
National promotional Banks and
institutions um so I think this is a
type of public part public private
partnership which is largely underused
in my view all around the world uh we
have a big funds of course the KKR or
the mcar or whatever you know that they
go around and they invest they have a
mission or whatever um but I think they
not always go into the areas where uh
let's say an initial investment could
help the risking and facilitating a
certain virtuous process sorry just
thank you so much so yeah combination
private uh public is is key to find the
the right balance and the right
mechanism maybe let's move to something
more maybe bit more operational because
once you have the public policy once you
have the funding it's not the end of the
game um we we we t in the report on on
this concept of competition policy and
infrastructure sharing infrastructure
sharing is really all about how do we
help the different
stakeholder um not necessarily um
overbuilding each other not necessarily
you know over investing when it's
possible to achieve the same goal for
for the benefits of of citizens by
having a bit more a smarter approach uh
sharing infrastructure
uh but that needs to be organized uh and
this is what competition policy is also
all about um maybe want a few words on
on this
topic thanks um Vincent just to add to
what you're saying you know and and to
just sort of close the loop on on a a
potential PPP you know public funds can
set down very specific rules around um
you know accessing that funding for
instance um funding may not be applied
in a in a area where there's an overbo
um you know so government can lay down
some really strict rules when it comes
to um which operators can um fund that
um you know there's a lot of models
across upar in Africa um you know South
Africa I think is is almost known as The
Land of Open Access where networks are
built um you know passive Network
infrastructure are built and then isps
go and on sell those services so um from
an infrastructure sharing Point um at at
that layer
um it's been hugely successful um and
now we you know there's more and more
Open Access networks that are being
built globally including in the US um
you know where as as far as five years
back they didn't have a single Open
Access Network so there's some
popularity that's coming around around
um neutral host networks or Open Access
networks or or you know what what you'd
like to call it but then of course
there's also infrastructure sharing
where you know we you facilitate at a
facilities level um where there's
potential duct sharing um you know or
sharing with government who are
deploying um infrastructure at um at
certain uh layers access to Street
Furniture we know that that's a um you
know that that's an ongoing problem um
and um well so I think we know that that
will reduce cost everybody agrees on it
the biggest problem that we're facing
very often in Africa is that
unfortunately too often government look
at the Talco sector and they think that
there's a lot of margin um and you know
they they often say oh this is the
sector that makes so much money we know
you know you guys make a lot of money
and they think that they can um derive
revenues out of the sector so either
placing very expensive um right of-way
application fees um or um in some
countries there's even per meter charges
um that are that are implemented on
fiber networks being deployed um and and
you know your your own um sanity must
tell you a per meter charge is only
going to have an impact on the most
rural people stay the furthest from
where operators are building so there's
a compound effect on on Rural
communities um you know who are looking
to this so we're making some progress
we've seen some um fees cut or um or
massively reduced in the last couple of
years and you know which which is really
heartwarming but we still not um have
that level where government is saying
hey make use of our infrastructure use
the street lights um you know to deploy
in especially vulnerable areas um where
we struggling um you know to to get
investment and to get um Broadband
deployment um you know out there um the
other thing around uh competition policy
is that um you know we appreciate um
competition is critically important and
of course we want to see competition but
this is not um this is not a game for
the faint at heart you know it's
expensive to deploy infrastructure um
it's in specifically expensive to deploy
fiber we're expecting that you know the
markets and as we see them globally have
four or five players um lots of small
companies coming out building small
networks and then off selling them uh
one particular model that um has been
happening uh very successfully in
subsaharan Africa is a build operat and
transfer model so we seeing small
companies raise a bit of funding they go
they acquire right of-way approvals they
construct the networks um and then they
sell them to operators they get their
money and they they repeat the cycle and
they you know they they continue to
build um which has been a very
interesting model you know because these
are typically companies that understand
the standards for deployment Etc and you
know they raise Capital to build smaller
um networks and that's extensively
helped operators is um scale their
networks because they don't have to go
through um you know the operational
cumbersome uh project of building out
and for many of them you know it becomes
a capex you know so they it comes out of
the acquisition budget because they're
requiring so they can continue uh to
build out you know from a Opex point of
view um but um it's only because of
market failure and because the operators
are just not building fast enough and
you know there are opportunities for
that but um you know very interesting
competition time we've seen the Voom CVH
transaction last year was declined by
the competition commission it's now
under under review again um and although
you know one um one wants to have a very
robust competitive landscape you
sometimes also you know are concerned
that um some of this you know you're
going to have to you know everybody's
building to sell everybody's like you
know have to continuously invest in
network expansion and without ongoing
Acquisitions and um you know some of the
deals taking place uh we're just going
to run out of capital to continue
investing so it's just striking that
balance right and making sure that we
know where the one should start and the
other on should end not overreaching
allowing market dynamics to continue um
and to find how to develop very
competitive markets um um without
stifling Innovation and stifling
growth well thank you one and and
somehow you you also touch upon what um
we were planning to to address in the
next topic which is more usage of um
public asset because this is all uh
inter
interconnected um in uh in this topic um
Dr suan uh so on um infrastructure
sharing I I I remember you you mentioned
some Open Access model being also
organized um do do you see the same
Trend uh towards corporation uh and
management of uh of this Corporation and
and this competition between Market
players yes I remember in in in the
early days of ftth deployment especially
here in Saudi Arabia uh there is a
competition between two or three
operators where they all invest in in
building their uh fiber networks and was
uh a land grab
mechanism what they were doing simply
because they were targeting the
high-profit areas uh in metropolitan
areas and and and with time you know
when when things are changing and other
players are coming into the market you
know now we see there is an appetite for
for open uh access and also for
infrastructure infrastructure sharing
infrastructure sharing was uh in the
beginning uh basically sharing the
trench then sharing the duct and now
they are sharing actually the networks
which is a very good sign and I don't
believe that operators should really own
their own networks they could utilize
somebody else's Network unfortunately
private
Investments are lacking simply because
the regulation prevent prevents them
from from investing in in in
infrastructure in building the
infrastructure or owning uh the fiber
networks in most of of uh Mina countries
the network is always controlled by the
UN compon operator and then they can
sell to others or they can bit stream
lease to
other however I think nowadays it's it's
changing a little bit uh now many
countries are adopting the Open Access
whereby the consumer has a choice to
choose from different operators
utilizing uh any network that is
available in in the area that they
reside in which is a good sign uh of
course the rural areas are are much less
advantagous because they are relying on
Universal Services Universal Services uh
they lack the Broadband capabilities
because they mostly Wireless or or
microwave based uh however after
covid-19 I think many governments are
paying attention to this uh so they are
uh putting some funds to uh extend the
networks uh to include the roller areas
for example uh three four years ago uh
Egypt introduced decent life initiatives
whereby they were uh targeting to uh
interconnect uh 40,000 small villages in
Egypt with fiber Broadband unfortunately
due to the economic difficulties that
Egypt is facing this project has slowed
down
tremendously in Saudi Arabia there is a
big project going on uh which should
start actually in a few months which
will uh utilize adss cable to uh
connect all the villages that are far
away or or or in the mountains which is
a very good sign now because they are
realizing that Universal Services is not
working for broadband and for the demand
of more bandwidth from
citizens so it's progressing
uh and also uh we really need to focus
on on uh attracting uh some private
Investments we need to really uh focus
on uh municipalities I think they should
also uh start investing on on owning uh
networks in certain area whereby and
they can lease it to operators uh
unfortunately uh most governments are
still thinking that incomp operator
should own the network and and and and
disag agree with this totally because at
the end of the day an operator should
focus on Services rather than owning
assets and and we should really attract
more like private Equity
municipalities uh communities to really
invest in in their own Network and and
and and serve the the citizens residing
in these
networks well thank you very much for
for your view on this uh moving to you
Franco um a lot of activity at the
European uh level has taken place
recently specifically on on this topic
on on how to facilitate accelerate
deployment using uh public asset sharing
infrastructure and doing that in in the
best uh in the best possible way so I
think you you have quite a few few
things to say on on this topic indeed uh
yes I mean since since uh probably a
couple of decades we started regulating
these matter quite quite heavily of
course I mean 20 years ago we were
coming out of the regulation of of the
market and the privatization of of the
incumbents in the various member states
but now the story
continues what is in the pipeline at
European level we have essentially two
main two main piece of uh policies
regulations the first one is a
recommendation to the member states
actually to the nas national regular
authorities because as you probably know
in the union we have 27 regulators and
we have a board of those Regulators that
is uh helping coordinating between them
and also interfacing with with the
commission so it's a quite articulated
uh governance structure I would say but
it works relatively well so far so we as
I said we are working on the new gigabit
recommendation which will replace uh now
quite becoming quite obsolete uh Next
Generation access recommendation of the
say 2010 or so and the
non-discrimination non-discriminatory
and cost um uh methodology uh
recommendation again we can only
recommend the member states and the
nraas in this in this field so but in
essence the main objective what what it
is about it is about uh gu giving
guidance to the nraas about conditions
to be imposed on operators that are
proven to have a significant Market
power concerning the accessing of their
infrastructures so this way we
incentivize the switch off of legac
infrastructures because of course this
triggers a bit of competition and shakes
a little bit the the snps to move on um
and promote of course uh pricing
flexibility for access to regulated
networks uh all of these to Foster
competition and improve a customer of
course uh advantages for the customers
uh of course the operators might or
might not necessarily like all of this
uh but that's it I mean this is the way
we we so there is there are a lot of
provision in this concerning the
geographical segregation because of
course not all regions are the same the
definition of the market and the
definition of the various remedies
according also to the type of Market the
way it is working even at the local
level uh ensuring of course
um for what concerns the
non-discrimination is of course ensuring
the that there is equivalence of access
given to the possible uh other operators
ensuring technical replicability of The
Operators offer uh and also
incentivizing the switch off this is one
of the import most important drivers for
us uh now I understand van because of
lack of time you wanted also to cover
the other part which is about
infrastructure sharing that is the
second thing if you allow me to say this
is the G gigabit um the G Gia gigabit
infrastructure act that that we are also
working on of course in this moment the
floor is up to the to the um uh
Parliament and the council but we count
really both those uh will be approved in
the coming months before the end of the
Mandate this Gia is more about really
digitalizing the whole permit
granting uh process making sure that uh
that those databases of
of other infrastructure are are
accessible to each other actually to The
Operators and to sorry to to those who
have to to to deploy the networks um the
Gia is about also uh transparency and
last but not least I'll will be very
short for the first time really we enter
into the homes of people so we really uh
try to prescribe and this will be
European law will not be a direct it
will be enforceable directly because
it's a reg regulation really try to
enforce a fiberization let's say of
inside the homes uh with the compliance
to certain standards and um make this
mandatory for every new building or
building which is which is which is
undergoing important
restoration um so that's that's I think
most of what we can do at this
stage yeah well thank you very much
Franco and thank you for for keeping
this very complex matter uh into a a
very nutshell presentation um I think we
we're approaching the end of of the
session so um what I would like to
encourage everyone is to to to go to the
to the report you which once again you
can immediately download from the hands
out but which also will be accessible
from the website of uh each organization
the ftth Cil Europe but also digital
Africa or Fiber connect min
will have the the report
available and I would also encourage uh
each of you to follow the activity of
the of the different different councils
uh because this topic of public policy
regulation are also an important topic
we cover via um our activity our report
or our event um and with that uh I would
like to to thank very much our panel uh
Franco Wanita Dr suan it was really nice
to to get your Insight uh and share with
our audience the variety of situation
across the globe uh next session at 5:00
pm we'll uh we'll talk about the same
subject but with more emphasis on the
situation uh in North America and Latin
America uh and we will also be able to
compare the situation with with Europe
and and other region maybe a few words
to conclude to the panel if you have a
last comment to
share Penta starting with you great
thanks everyone Vincent just thank you
for um for organizing this and your team
in in Europe put this together thank you
it's it's very helpful and um it's
always great to also just hear from
other people and um Dr suan great to see
you again Franco nice to meet you and
have a have a good rest of the
day big thank also on my
side thank you so much I I would like to
maybe uh just raise a point that is very
important this is probably the first
time that we have commonly discussed the
policy and regulation with respect to
ftth deployment and I think the analysis
were perfect and and I encourage
everyone to really go through this uh uh
paper that that that was developed
however I think there should be uh
further steps to uh make common
recommendations for all regions uh to
follow uh as a
benchmark it's very important and I
think it's also uh very important to
really Let The Regulators know uh what
we are doing as far as this and what are
the recommendation of from the agencies
and the stakeholders that actually work
in the field I think it's very helpful
it will definitely improve all Broadband
activities in all regions around the
world thank you so much for inviting me
thank you my side really I I embrace
this last proposal of course this is a
kind of helicopter view what we are
discussing but uh of course it's up to
you to see if other sessions more deep
Dives would be important we would
certainly be available to to contribute
thank you again to Dr suan to Dr Clark
and to you Vana for hosting this quite
interesting session oh pleasure thanks
thanks for for audience um yeah and well
I I wish you a good rest of your day see
you on many of our next session
organized by uh all of organization the
Ft conference coming in Berlin very soon
so I hope you you enjoy the session and
we will see you at at another occasion
thank you so much thank you bye bye bye
byee